Hi!
My name is Colt MCAnlis, and I am a Developer
Advocate for Native Client.
In this video, I am going to explain how you
can get started using Native Client to create
applications.
The first thing you need to do is get the
SDK and run naclsdk update.
This downloads and unpacks the up-to-date
tools, headers and libraries that you’ll
need to build Native Client applications.
Then my recommendation is to become more familiar
with Pepper.
Pepper is a set of bindings that expose the
power of the web platform to C and C++, giving
your program the same capabilities that JavaScript
has.
You can start by running some of the examples
and inspect their code.
Understanding the build process is also critical.
Start by running the SCons builders, and then
look at the output.
Once you familiarized yourself with Native
Client’s basic architecture, then you are
ready to build your project.
If you are porting or building your app from
an existing code base, then you’ll need
to make three key changes:
First you’ll need to make your C and C++
source code portable; for that use only the
portable dialect of C and C++.
Second you will need to use the Pepper interfaces
to access resources like graphics, audio,
and input devices.
This step makes the resulting application
OS-independent, because Pepper is an OS-independent
API.
Third if your application uses hardware accelerated
graphics, you will need to adapt it to use
OpenGL ES 2.0.
Once your project is done, then you need to
package it as a Chrome Web Store app - this
way you will be able to reach more than 200
millions Chrome users.
To learn more on how to use Native Client
check out our documentation at gonacl.com.